gewaltige sonnenstürme erschüttern das
erdmagnetfeld und stellen eine
permanente bedrohung für uns menschen da
nicht einmal die iss also die
internationale raumstation iss sicher
wenn das erdmagnetfeld erschüttert wird
was dazukommt sonnenstürme sind kaum
vorherzusagen doch jetzt ist es einem
forschungsteam aus london gelungen mit
hilfe von satelliten dem geheimnis der
weltraum leben auf die spur zu kommen
auf welche art und weise genau das
magnetische schutzschild der erde
vibriert und ob diese erkenntnisse das
leben auf der erde vor den fatalen
folgen von sonnenstürmen schützen kann
pixum science fiction hier gibt es
täglich faszinierendes seines videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann und nur
dann verpasst ihr nichts herzlich
willkommen sondern ihren sohn sind
wirklich ein super spannendes phänomen
dabei wird aus der sonnenatmosphäre eine
gigantische wolke aus unvorstellbar als
im gas heraus gesteuert
die dabei ausgestoßenen teilchen
protonen können im weltall
geschwindigkeiten von mehreren millionen
stundenkilometern erreichen es formen
sich plasmawolken und dadurch entstehen
magnetische stürme in unserer
erdatmosphäre
dann bringt röntgenstrahlung in die
ionosphäre ein und verändert die
eigenschaften so dass sich
beispielsweise funkwellen nicht mehr
ausbreiten können vor allem kurz und
ultra kurzwellen sind betroffen
dort findet vor allem der amateur und
mobilfunk stadt doch auch gps kann
betroffen seien aber auch fatale folgen
für die stromversorgung auf der erde
können sonnenstürme mit sich bringen
denn riesige transformatoren werden dann
gegrillt und nicht nur das es gibt auch
fachleute die zwischen sonnen ausbrüchen
und naturkatastrophen hier auf der erde
einen zusammenhang sehen taifune
erdbeben und auch besonders gigantische
hurricanes whw und immer könnten ihnen
direkte folgen von sonneneruptionen sein
fest steht also sonneneruptionen können
auch der erde und uns menschen sehr
gefährlich werden selbst wenn der
abstand zwischen sonne und erde 150
millionen kilometer beträgt und uns auch
die erdatmosphäre einen gewissen schutz
bietet wenn die ausgestoßenen partikel
die erde allerdings ohne unterlass
bombardieren würden könnte ab
kein leben auf unserem planeten
existieren gut also dass ist das
irdische magnetfeld gibt das den
aggressiven sonnenwind um uns herum
lenkt und das schlimmste verhindern doch
klar ist das erdmagnetfeld wird durch
sonnenstrom erschüttert und zur form die
feldlinien werden auf der sonne
zugewandten seite stark zusammengedrückt
auf der abgewandten seite dagegen werden
die linien wie ein schweif
auseinandergezogen das ganze lässt
kompassnadeln vibrieren und polarlichter
leuchten schon vor knapp 50 jahren wurde
fachleuten klar dass das magnetfeld der
erde in schwingung versetzt wird wenn es
von einer teilchenwolken getroffen wird
doch das krasse daran bis heute konnten
solche stehenden wellen nicht
nachgewiesen werden
dazu der wissenschaftler martina von der
queen mary university in londen es gibt
spekulationen dass diese trommel
ähnlichen vibrationen vielleicht gar
nicht entstehen
seit ihrer vorhersage vor 45 jahren die
belege gewesen
eine andere möglichkeit wahr dass sie
einfach sehr schwer
definitiv nachzuweisen sind doch jetzt
endlich gelang der entscheidende
durchbruch und das team um archer konnte
zeigen wie das magnetische schutzschild
der erde vibriert und zwar wie die wohl
größte trommel der welt dieser erfolg
gelang dem britischen forschungsteam mit
hilfe der aufnahmen der fünf
nasa-satelliten vermißt diese waren
genau zur richtigen zeit am richtigen
ort sie waren gerade korrekten position
gebracht als ein riesiger impuls von der
sonne für ein spektakel sorgte das
irdische magnetfeld schlug tatsächlich
ähnlich an wie ein trommel klöppel in
tag sprache ausgedrückt gelang in diesem
moment der nachweis stehende wellen eben
wie sie sich auch auf dem fell einer
trommel ausbilden dazu archer
wir haben die größte trommel der welt in
der krise trommelt ist dutzende mal
größer als der planet erde
diese erkenntnis überträgt das
forschungsteam auf andere planeten
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler vermuten dass auch die
magnet schilde von saturn jupiter und
merkur auf dieselbe art und weise
schwingen jetzt wollen die fachleute
untersuchen wie häufig solche
vibrationen vorkommen und welche folgen
sie mit sich bringt spannende
fragestellungen die im besten fall so
schnell wie möglich beantwortet werden
bisher sind wir in diesem themenbereich
er unwissend unterwegs wir spielen quasi
russisches roulette mit der sonne
zwar sähen teleskope und erster
satelliten den ausbruch der sonne
doch dann muss auch eingeschätzt werden
wie stark der ausbruch ist und ob er die
erde überhaupt treffen wird erst 20
minuten bevor der sturm die erde
erreicht ist dann auch klar in welche
richtung sein magnetfeld zeigen wird und
das ist entscheidend dafür wie gut er
das irdische magnetfeld durchdringen
wird wichtig wäre als also die prozesse
auf der sonne besser zu verstehen um sie
dann irgendwann einmal auch exakt
vorhersagen zu können
der europäische balaur bitter der
anfangs 2020 aufbrechen soll könnte dazu
enorm beitragen und wie gefährlich
sonnenstürme sind erfahrt ihr hier
draufklicken anschauen und abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran